Harlem is one of the greatest
communities in the world the way I help
the community is through food I'm JJ
johnson chef and founder of field trip
in Harlem I love the holidays because I
get to be with my family and my friends
but there's a lot of people out there
that are just unable to be around their
family and friends so it's a good time
to really give back so state farms
mission is to help people and I'm gonna
do the same by doing what I love cooking
so in the spirit of the holidays I'm
going to be cooking one of my favorite
dishes and I'm gonna share this recipe
with my neighborhood so the deep dish
crab mac and cheese feels like a warm
hug and it's a perfect dish to share
with others so just some salt so my
pastas super flavorful some elbow
macaroni and only one stir so that it
doesn't stick to the bottom of the pan
this is all about the cheese sauce right
here so we're gonna start with some
butter some rosemary toast a rosemary a
little bit and there's nothing like
giving a dish to somebody that
represents your home and who you are
this is my family kind of in this
ultimate crab mac and cheese now the
cream is reduced where I need it to be
reduced and I'm gonna add in some of my
favorite cheese Gouda so good I picked
the Gouda cheese for the smokiness
I picked the Parmesan cheese for the
saltiness and I picked the cheddar for
the creaminess I'm ready I'm ready
I'm getting excited my grandmother's
taught me how to spread joy through
cooking and I continually keep spreading
that joy through every rice bowl that we
put out at field trip or taking over our
local pantry to help people in need
jumbo lump crabmeat so good make sure
there's no shells that's why I tested
one out and don't start too hard cuz
then you're gonna break up that
beautiful crabmeat
some butter the lemons s oh it smells
great it smells very citrusy this is
gonna bring it all together I have my
mac and cheese here look at this
and God creamy this is if you gave this
to somebody they would be really happy
my bread crumb topping just sprinkle it
all over I want to get this everywhere
maybe even the table and then I'm gonna
finish it with some scallions so now it
goes in the oven at 350 degrees for 10
minutes oh this looks amazing like look
at the creaminess in the bottom the nice
crispy crust I'm ready to eat so I
always try my food before I give it to
everybody else this is good if I have
seen you here behind me I would just
like slide on down in the sheet but this
feels like home I'm getting that nice
hug so I'm super excited to give my
deep-dish crab mac and cheese to people
at the shelter today so we're in East
Harlem at the Bowery mission where it's
all about restoring and rebuilding hope
given to my neighbors is really
important uplifting the community that I
live in and have a restaurant in when
you're giving back and just look right
in your own neighborhood and if you just
look around a little bit more you'll see
who's in need come on why are you still
watching this get bacon get Mackin
[Music]